hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Q&A about future of Science
and Technology and I see there are lots
of questions here
[Music]
um question here not sure if I've talked
about this another time but um I'm happy
to talk about it uh from
Larry how will the future of mathematics
change so partly depends on what one
means by
mathematics there's kind of a an
activity of exploring kind of
mathematical
kinds of ideas and then there's the sort
of social practice among mathematicians
of doing what they call mathematics and
these are not necessarily quite the same
thing I mean I think one thing to say
about mathematics is there's this
methodology that tends to exist that
says kind of you write a math paper and
it's like your goal is invent a theorem
and then give a proof of that
theorem and well why is the the true
well in the end the theorem has to rest
on certain axioms at least implicitly
certain things that you kind of state a
true like you know uclid was an original
person a couple of thousand years ago
who started stating axioms so he had
axioms like uh
statements like for instance um on a
line between any two points there's
another point or another very famous
axim that he had was two parallel lines
can never CR cross his fifth postulate
well that was something you can prove a
lot of stuff from the assumption that
two parallel lines never cross but you
can still ask the question is that Axiom
actually true in some for example for
our universe and what became clear in
1915 with Einstein's general theory of
relativity is that no actually in the
space time that exists space that exists
in our actual Universe it can be curved
so two parallel lines can in fact cross
in space in our universe so that axium
of uids isn't true for our universe it's
a perfectly reasonable thing to set up a
mathematics to prove things on the basis
of that Axiom but it isn't something
which will be true in our physical
universe and this is sort of a general
feature of mathematics you set up axioms
and then you prove what's true at least
that's how people sort of Imagine
mathematics is set up and they've been
imagining that for about bit more than a
100 years this idea that mathematics is
this kind of effort to Define formal
aims then prove what you can from those
formal aims whether or not those formal
axim are for example in any sense true
about our physical Universe they're just
kind of statements of formal things from
which you can make proofs now back when
that was all being started when people
were really excited about those things
from the 1880s to early early part of
the 20th century uh this was kind of
where it was at in terms of formalism
leads to con consquences but then
starting in 1920 developing in the 1930s
then really developing in the last few
decades computation the idea of having
uh something where you could start from
rules and then work out the consequences
of those rules but do it in this very
direct way you you've got these rules
for how for example the state of a
system should be transformed you just
apply the rules over and over and over
again it makes a computation it gives
you a series of results that's something
very much more direct than what you're
doing in mathematics where you say well
I've got this theorem and I kind of want
to see whether I can piece together from
axioms to get to that theorem and you
kind of have to find this path from it's
kind of a non-deterministic computation
problem of finding this path from the
axioms to the theorem you happen to want
to prove but but more to the point as I
say mathematics as conceived 100 years
ago was kind of this idea of we've got
formal rules formal aums and then we see
what their consequences are and this was
the the the environment the framework in
which that type of idea was played out
more recently that type of idea is
played out much more powerfully in
computation very much more direct you've
just got these rules you see their
consequences and so on so one of the
things that I think is a feature of
mathematics is when you think about
doing experiment Al mathematics just try
and run things and based on these
mathematical rules and so on and see
what's true that's more like doing
computations what has been the more the
traditional mathematics is assert from
somewhere come up with something you
think is true some theorem and then find
this path by which you can prove that
from the axioms but this idea of
experimental mathematics which has been
sort of a a an undercurrent in a lot of
the great mathematical work that's been
done over the course of centuries I
think that experimental mathematics the
idea of just find what's true
computationally is is a key part of what
can be the future of
mathematics now one question is is that
field which consists of finding out
what's true on the basis of various
kinds of rules and is that what people
would normally call mathematics well
when it comes to computational rules
that's the field that I've recently been
calling rology the you know start with a
computational rule see its consequences
when those rules are things about oh you
have just this array of cells and you do
this thing updating the array of cells
based on colors of neighboring cells and
so on that feels more like rology if I
were to state that same kind of thing as
a rule in terms of what you do to some
mathematical formula how you iterate
some mathematical formula it will sound
more like traditional mathematics it
will sound more like something stated in
the in the language of
mathematics so I think but I think that
this idea of just find out what's true
computationally is sort of a key
Direction in mathematics which has been
really has not been pursued as much as
it it could be I mean I myself have made
a bunch of discoveries with that
methodology I've encouraged other people
over decades to do that and and some
have really made great careers out of
doing that but it's surprisingly
untypical it's it's kind of a
mathematics is this strange field of
science like stuff where the purely
theoretical field is much bigger than
the experimental field in most areas
like physics or something there are many
more people doing experiments than sort
of trying to invent Theory but
mathematics isn't that way now you know
if you ask well what is the um what what
is the sort of picture of the of
mathematics as it is so one point is
when you start talking about formal
about axium systems and formalization of
mathematics and the idea that you can
start with arbitrary ax
and those axioms are really uncoupled
with what's actually true in the world
actual practicing mathematicians will
find that for the most part an alien
view of mathematics that's not what they
think they're doing they think they are
taking the the the sort of mathematics
as it has been developed and sort of
building on what's been developed and
sort of adding pieces to what's been
developed rather than going down to
these micro aums my kind of analogy is
if you're doing studying a fluid like
water or something you can go all the
way down to the molecules and be
studying what each individual molecule
does it's kind of like the axima
approach to mathematics or you can be
trying to work out the equations of
fluid flow and study the fluid at the
level of kind of large scale motions and
so on and that second thing is more what
the typical mathematician thinks they're
doing when you drop down to the level of
axioms and to this kind of
submicroscopic this sort of microscopic
level then you've got all kinds of
different metam mathematical phenomena
that that go on but this this even the
possibility of doing mathematics
consistently sort of at this fluid
dynamics level it's not obvious that
that would be possible and one of the
things I I just wrote this book actually
what is it nearly a year ago now about
the physicalization of met mathematics
which is all about trying to understand
this uh kind of this idea of kind of
higher level mathematics as compared to
things like axima mathematics and part
of the starting point for that book is
kind of looking at the network of all
possible theorems of mathematics I mean
in the in the published literature of
mathematics there three or four million
theorems that have been accumulated over
the last couple of thousand years and
from one theorem one Axiom axioms are
just theorems you assume to be true
rather than ones you imagine you can
prove from the axioms or or theorems
that we already have established you're
building up this whole network you can
build up an infinite network of possible
theorems of mathematics and the question
is well what is that structure of that
space of possible theorems and one of
the things that uh I think is is kind of
you can ask that question analogously to
the way you can ask that question about
the structure of physical space we now
think in our physics project that
physical space underneath is just this
this network of relations between atoms
of space so it too is discrete and what
in physical space is an atom of space in
matter mathematics is a theorem and but
they're both just sort of things that
are out there connected together by
various kinds of relations and so one of
the big things that we notice about
physical space is that for us humans it
seems to be continuous and that's
because we as as sort of finite Minds
observing all of this complexity of
these atoms of space we aggregate that
to the point where what we notice is
just this continuous structure of space
and so it is I think with mathematics
the fact is that the human mathematical
Observer is kind of most of the time not
going down to the level of sort of the
axioms or below the axioms but is rather
aggregating things so they can talk
about things like the Pythagorean
theorem as just a a theorem that we can
just intuitively have a sense of even
though there are ways to drill down and
turn that theorum into micro axioms
there may be many ways to do that but
that doesn't matter we don't have to
know exactly what we mean by a number
and things like this we have an
intuitive sense of how Pythagorean
theorem works so the possibility of
doing higher level mathematics is a
feature I think that is something for
sort of human mathematicians with finite
Minds just as the belief that there is a
continuous space in the universe is a
feature of us with finite Minds
observing the physical world so in any
case what does that mean for the future
mathematics well you know those three or
four million theorems of mathematics we
can explore an infinite number of
theorems there's the question of which
of those theorems do we humans care
about it's kind of like in in the
physical space that exists on the
surface of the Earth where do we
actually hang out and and colonized so
to speak where do we put our cities and
where is just sort of space that's
sitting on the surface of the Earth
without without humans hanging out there
it's the same thing in metam
mathematical space where do we choose to
sort of put the places where we're kind
of populating it with actual mathematics
that we make theorems and and put them
in papers and so on well I think what
we're seeing is sort of the steady sort
of growth in this metam mathematical
space of these sort of towers of uh of
theorems that we build that we that we
decide we care about and that we write
down in the in the uh uh publications of
mathematics and so on and I think that
we will see these sort of these prongs
of mathematics continue to grow out one
thing that is sort of an observation
about a lot of kind of the the Leading
Edge of mathematics is these remarkable
kind of dualities between different
areas of mathematics it's been known for
well 3 400 years now that algebra and
geometry have a certain Duality things
that you can represent geometrically you
know I've got a circle and it's got
lines going through it and it intersects
another Circle and so on you can write
down algebraic equations that represent
that situation and similarly many
algebraic equations you can also
represent in terms of geometrical
figures and their properties so that's a
that's a duality that is uh has been
known for a long time what's sort of
emerged in the last few decades is these
Grand dualities between different areas
of mathematics and we're seeing lots of
dualities and my guess is that that's
sort of a feature of the structure of
meta mathematical space that that it's
kind of like physical space is kind of
homogeneous you can move a thing from
one place to another so similarly a meta
mathematical space you can move from one
place to another and that represents
this kind of this this this dualities
between different areas of mathematics
and I think that's a thing we'll see
more of and we'll see kind of the
ultimate unity of mathematics which is
ultimately computational ultimately
deeply related to this object I call the
ruad which is this kind of entangled
limit of all possible computations in a
sense that's the ultimate future of
mathematics is to fill out the ruad but
the fact is that that if we were to do
that there would not be things that we
can connect to in a human kind of way we
will be kind of filling out everything
and sort of have nothing as a result so
in a sense part of what mathematics is
is this human activity of kind of
filling out different areas for which we
can which we describe as being
mathematics we care about just like we
have words for certain Concepts in in a
natural language that we care about and
there are other sort of interc concept
OB things in interc concept space that
are different kinds of constructs for
which we don't have words and I think
it's the same kind of thing in
mathematics so as a practical matter uh
my guess is is there will be more sort
of unification in mathematics at the at
the sort of abstract level there will be
I hope more experimental mathematics of
finding things that are true and where
it's really what what's what's an issue
is which things do we humans care about
and uh I think those are those are
things we can see happen I think these
the effort to just sort of say let's
turn all of mathematics into a
formalized system where we can just
kind of go from aims we choose and just
grind out everything I think that's kind
of a a Fool's errand because I think
that what will happen is that most of
what really matters in mathematics is
this very human aesthetic question of
what do we humans care about and so on
simply grinding out the theorems
mechanically is is not what we usually
think of as humanlike mathematics it's
it's kind of the uh uh it's it's it's
something something alien something
kind of uh it's it's like saying imagine
all possible uh all possible Concepts
imagine all possible things that can
computationally happen most of those are
not things that we have a human
connection to and so I don't think those
get to be what we will normally call
mathematics now in terms of uh what can
will happen sort of sociologically in
mathematics I think the typical
mathematical paper for example can say
what I think should have happen I mean
one of the things that is often very
missing is the why are you doing this
type question you know a mathematics
paper will start off by saying you know
these are the definitions now we're
going to do the following thing it's
like why are we doing this we have no
idea there's a certain Trend uh to make
mathematics more more explain why it's
doing what it's doing which I think is
very good that's the sort of more
humanization of mathematics because
that's in the end what true mathematics
is really about to say it's it's this
mechanical thing just comes from axioms
is to kind of deny the what is I think
important about mathematics for us
humans well I think there's this
question of whether questions that we
have in mathematics whether they have to
be ground down to the level of kind of
mechanical axiomatic work if that
happens there will be things like
undecidability the fact that given a
particular set of axioms there may not
be any finite proof you can give of
either a statement or the uh negation of
that statement it may be something
that's independent of those axioms and
there sort of a question of will that
happen a lot well I my I was was was
very for decades actually curious about
why that didn't happen more than it does
and I think the answer is that this
human level mathematics is almost
defined to not drop down to this sort of
acatic level where that's a common
phenomenon it's defined to operate sort
of at this fluid dynamics level where
those kinds of things don't go on now
now you know another question you can
ask is with all the emphasis on AI and
llms and all this kind of thing you can
ask the question given that we know
three or four million theorems of
mathematics and we have this mechanical
process for producing new theorems can
we make the llms be sort of proxies for
us humans and decide what directions we
will think are interesting and that's a
good question and we've been doing some
experiments on that and I don't think I
know the answer yet I know a few cases
where yes there is kind of a good
heuristic for deciding what theorems
humans will be will will care about
essentially one case of that heuristic
is for the theorems of Blan algebra of
logic where the ones we put in our
textbooks are precisely the ones it
turns out only 14 of them where those
theorems are simpler statements of what
they contain than that they're the
simplest statements of sort of the the
mathematical content they contain and
everything else is an embellishment on
that and it's the sort of the minimal
ones that we actually put in our
textbook so that's one particularistic
but I think an interesting question is
is there a more General thing that the
AIS have sort of picked up from looking
at human mathematics that says oh these
are things the humans are going to care
about just like if you're doing image
generation it's like the AI can say this
is a picture the human is going to think
is beautiful in some way you can kind of
prompt it to say show me a beautiful
picture or and it will have some idea of
what that means based on pictures that
billions of pictures that's seen which
have been tagged in various Ways by
humans all right long answer that
question
uh there a question here from cloud
asking what would there be a way to use
the moon as a gravitational Tugboat to
slowly tow the Earth away from the
expanding surface of of the sun when it
becomes a red giant so we can stay in a
in a nice temperate zone of the solar
system well when does the sun um I think
the
Sun what do we have about another four
billion years before the sun turns into
a r giant I'm not sure of that order but
I think um uh the eventually it will
expand to more or less get out to the
orbit of Jupiter uh so the question is
what do we do with the Earth at that
point um I don't know there's the
science fiction story wandering Earth
where where people have put rocket
engines on the earth so to speak to
slowly move it um out of the solar
system I think um it's
uh uh the the getting the Earth to sort
of um uh go fast enough to sort of move
move to a different orbit around the sun
means you have to make it go not quite
100,000 miles an hour which is the
escape velocity of the Sun but something
close to that and uh how would you
achieve that I don't know I think it's
quite challenging um certainly with um
uh I don't think it works to um uh I'd
be I think the yes the Earth Moon system
I mean I I don't think we get to change
much about it um it is what it is and to
move it around requires
um would require all sorts of uh pushing
so to speak now an interesting question
is if we knew we had if we knew we had a
million years before anything needed to
be done is there a way that we could set
up a pretty weak kind of rocket engine
on the earth that would slowly slowly
start to push the Earth in a different
way um
I don't entirely know the answer to that
although as I say I think in the end I
mean that that that rocket engine would
have to be gradually uh increasing the
momentum of the earth so that eventually
it reaches that roughly 100,000 miles
hour speed in order to be able to move
around in the gravitational well of the
Sun so uh I think that's a you it's kind
of a long range plan so to speak you
know it's kind of funny I I somebody was
showing me
just a couple of days ago some uh uh for
a organization showing that that 230
plans and I'm like that's a fairly long
way away um and then I was remembering
back in the 1980s I remember visiting
some group in the Netherlands where they
were making plans for the dkes in the
Netherlands that uh because they they
you know parts of the country are below
below sea level and they use Dykes to
keep the keep the ocean out um kind of
like what people say is going to happen
if sea level rises in other places you
have to have dkes the Netherlands has
had them for a very very long time um
but uh that in terms of long-term
planning those guys were telling me they
have a 400-year plan for their dkes so
that's sort of a a longer range plan
than one usually hears about so maybe in
the case of the Earth moving around in
the solar system a million year plan
would uh um be uh uh
be be in
order let's
see kovani asks what future applications
do you think will come out being able to
measure atoc second uh time
scales so um uh atos second means 10
minus 18 seconds which is a million
trillionth of a second and uh it's um
let's see what happens in that um uh
a lot of things for example in in you
know in chemistry there are a lot of
things happening at the ftoc scale 10us
15 seconds uh by the time you're down at
the 10us 18 second scale that's higher
energy things are happening at that
scale what will happen from being able
to measure things at that scale it's a
good question
um you know I
think being able to see sort of
processes in action like chemical
reactions is is something that with sort
of ftoc laser pulses and things we're
we're being able to see and I think as
you get down to even shorter time scales
that's more of a where we get to see how
things happen rather than just seeing in
typically in in both chemistry and in
physics particle physics for example
when we see reactions between things we
just say there are these molecules going
in and by golly after eventually those
molecules come out in particle physics
we say you know two protons you know
Collide and outcome a Cascade of you
know pons and other things we we just
get to see what goes in what comes out
if we have some way to kind of you know
sort of click the shutter in effect for
our detector more and more quickly we
get to see more of the process by which
things
occur now you know I would say that
there are uh pieces of science that will
be very interesting to understand more
about will that for example if we knew
more about how fishing spontaneous
fishing Works in in nuclear physics what
would that tell us and is there are
there kind of engineering hacks that we
can use you know if we knew more about
how molecules actually interact in the
reactions that they have and we knew how
the molecules kind of danced around
changed their shape you know electron
clouds moved and so on would that allow
us to have sort of different Pathways
that we can invent for having processes
go on I think the answer is quite
possibly yes um in terms of of what the
world will look like at that kind of
scale it's an interesting question I
think one thing I was kind of curious
about thinking about a couple of weeks
ago is if we could think a million times
faster than we do uh you know imagine
our our brains are largely replaced by
Digital Electronics that's sort of
thinking a million times faster than we
do and what would we sense in the world
and it's it's pretty clear that for
example light goes one foot in a nanc
and for us a nanc is a really short time
for us with our current brains a nanc is
a really short time but if our brains
were running a million times faster a
nanc would be kind of more like the time
it takes to form a thought which for us
now is more in the many tens to hundreds
of
milliseconds so you know if you can form
a thought in a nanosecond then you don't
get to sort of aggregate the structure
of space in the same way that we
typically do you're you're you're much
more seeing the world in in these kind
of uh sort of the individual pieces of
light from different parts of the scene
that you're seeing are sort of arriving
at at at perceptibly different times and
no doubt you know phenomena of the kind
that you experience with sound with
Echoes and things like that you know
whenever a photon kind of is arriving
somewhere it's often sort of bouncing
around the room I mean that's why that's
why we can see objects in the room it's
because photons are being reflected from
those objects that's what we're actually
seeing when we see the objects and so
your your average photon is bouncing
around a bunch of times in the room if
there are mirrors it's it's more s it's
even more sort of convincingly sort of
bouncing from place to place and we get
to see that if we were on a at a second
time scale if we were thinking a million
times faster than we do those kinds of
things we'll get to see all of those all
of that we'll get to see sort of the
full complexity of what's actually
happening in the physics of the scenes
we're dealing with the fact that we see
things in this much more aggregated way
is I think important for us generating
this kind of human level narrative about
those things we're not used to seeing
things at the true physics level and it
will be very confusing to us with what
we currently know so it's sort of an
interesting uh uh question what what
that would really be
like
um well Rebel is asking do you see new
conjectures that could be made by
AIS uh or agis I'm not so keen on that
term because I'm not sure quite what it
means but but AI systems and how will
humans tackle the abstraction and
complexity of these um conjectures well
it's easy to do this I've I've done it a
lot in my life you just go out into the
computational universe of possible
programs and you run these programs and
they do all kinds of wild things and if
you say what's really going on can I
understand it a the human level of
narrative what's going on the answer is
often no I mean in a sense work I've
done has been about sort of taking that
rology and pulling it in at some level
to be a thing about which we can have
some level of human narrative some level
of description of you know there's four
classes of cellular autometer there's
these particular structures and so on
that occur it's a thing actually I'm
interested to see whether with modern
AIS whether we're able to take sort of
some of those things from the
computational world and say can we fit
them to things which are more sort of KN
inum Concepts how does that work uh I
again I don't know how well that's going
to work the very initial experiments
from couple of days ago were not
promising but these things tend to have
to mature a bit it's it's kind of like
you don't get a large language model in
a day it takes um lots of engineering
and and uh sort of trying different
things before you discover how to do
something like a large language model
the um
uh so you know when it comes to things
that AI invent and our ability to
understand them I think that we kind of
gradually expand our understanding we
gradually invent some New Concept we
give it a name we uh uh give some you
know we eventually invent some new
paradigm for thinking about things
that's a gradual process and we're
always connecting the next thing we
learn to the things we already knew and
in a sense that's a feature of sort of
the growth of science people that's what
people find it easy to do if you say
let's jump into this completely alien
world where you have no connection to
anything you already knew that's a very
difficult thing to do very difficult to
kind of Reason about things that are far
away from things you've reasoned about
before so I kind of think that the uh uh
this this question of of I mean
gradually people get more used to going
out on some sort of abstraction prong
and it's kind of like this question
about how come education doesn't take
much more time than it does given that
we know so much more in our civilization
why is it that even though we know more
that the time to get educated is not
changed that much in thousands of years
and I think the answer is because
there's more levels of abstraction in
what we learn now than what we learned
before you know when if before we had to
learn separately the the characteristics
of every animal that we now describe as
being a mammal now we just have to use
this abstract concept of a mammal and
immediately we know a lot of um a lot of
things that um about that particular
kind of
organism let's see there's some
questions here about physics and science
you I just
tweeted out uh a couple of days ago and
and just posted in a TED talk thing that
I gave from last week just posted some
videos uh that we just made about
features of our physics project one of
them was about a rendering sort of of
the beginning of the
universe well let's see this is kind of
a complicated story but but uh uh kind
of in our view of what the universe
what's in the universe what's the
universe made of first statement is the
only thing in the universe is space
everything is just a feature of the
structure of space all the particles all
the the gravity all those kinds of
things they're all features of the
structure of space just like if all we
have was a fluid it's made of molecules
but all these things these edes in the
fluid these different motions and so on
they're all made of combinations of
those molecules and so similarly what we
think is that in the structure of the
universe that everything is just made of
this kind of space which is this kind of
giant Network where there are discrete
atoms of space and just relations which
we can indicate as a graph with edges
that join the atoms of space and this
view of space in a sense 100 years ago a
little bit more than 100 years ago this
view of space would have been very
uncontroversial that is people were
wondering you know is matter continuous
so discreet is light continuous so
discreet Well turns out matter was
discovered around 1900 really is made of
molecules it's discreete light a little
bit later really is made of photons it's
discrete space well people kind of
thought it might be discreet too but
nobody ever figured out how to make that
work made a consistent Theory based on
that and that's what we managed to do in
the last few years and so we have this
view that space is discrete and what
this video is showing is the first few
starting from sort of what can be the
very beginning of the UN and when I when
I say what can be slightly complicated
story because many different things can
be the beginning of the universe they
are all different threads of time that
kind of go from those different
beginnings and the whole point is that
for us humans we are sort of embedded in
the thing that is our universe including
its many threads of time and when we
with our many threads of time uh try to
see how we perceive the universe we at
least believe that there's a definite
thread of time we believe we have to
conflate together those actual
underlying threads of time and so we're
with that belief with that way of
looking at the universe we are sort of
combining all these different initial
conditions for the universe and so on
but that video is is showing just one of
those initial conditions and it's
showing the the uh the kind of the
updating of the structure of this
network that represents space and
everything in space in the universe
and it's the the the the time in our
models is this sort of inexorable
computational updating of the structure
of space so the fact that relativity
works with these connections between
space and time is sort of an emergent
feature of how things work in our in our
models um but what that video is showing
is kind of this successive uh kind of
um successive kind of moments of time
and kind of the the updating of this of
the structure of space that represents
our whole universe um as as time
progresses and actually that that in
that there's sort of a red red parts of
the network those are the ones that just
got updated and it's sort of a big big
issue uh which ones get updated when
because the rule for updating just says
you can update whenever you feel like
but the actual rendering of this depends
on how you're observing it and so in
that particular video what was done was
to say everything that can be updated
now consistently without overlapping
something else that could be updated
just go ahead and update all those at
this moment and that's uh that sort of
has this idea that all of space is
updated at success moments in time you
don't have to do it that way a different
Observer would observe something
different happening though underneath
the sort of causal graph of what the
sequence of events that update that that
correspond to the updates that will
always be the same but our perception of
it and the way we render it is very
different and of course that that
rendering is just based on taking the
connectivity of the atoms of space and
just laying out the graph in a nice sort
of human human understandable way it's
not uh there's nothing intrinsic about
those atoms of space being placed at the
particular places they're placed the
only thing that's intrinsic is how those
atoms of space are connected to other
atoms of space so this is uh that's kind
of the idea and then this particular in
this particular Branch to an observer of
the kind that is being used to make that
video their conclusion about the
structure of spaces that it will be
about 2.6 dimensional which is kind of
weird um to a different kind of Observer
you would see something different there
but that's kind of the most generic
Observer and the one that's used for
that particular
rendering let's see
well I mean there's there's an awful lot
to say about a physics project one one
more question about that then I'll talk
about some other things SAR is asking
could I talk about bit about energy as a
flux of causal edges through space likee
hypersurfaces that's kind of the formal
statement of what energy is in our
models here's the intuition energy is
basically the amount of activity in the
network so energy is kind of the rate at
which things are changing in time it's
the rate at which updates are happening
but when you try and make that a little
bit more precise it's like well rate at
which they happening you know density of
updates what does it mean density space
we haven't defined space yet space is
being defined by the things that are
being updated and so on so you have to
be a little bit more precise and what
happens is you're looking at this causal
graph of this update happened then this
one happened there's certain updates
that must happen in a certain order but
because the input to One update uses the
output from another update so that
output the update whose output is being
used has to have happened before that
output is used to the input to some
other event so you build up this causal
graph of how these events are related
and some have to be in these kind of Tim
likee sequences of one than another than
another some can be space- likee
separate in the sense that those events
could be so just happening at different
places in space at the same time
simultane l so the the Flux Of causal
edges is basically saying imagine that
you've got this this causal graph and
you're saying okay there are these
things be which are space likee
separated in the sense that they don't
have to follow each other now there are
different ways that you can make a
foliation of this causal graph there
different ways that you can decide what
are the surfaces of simultaneity what
what which events are the ones we should
say happen simultaneously even though
they happening at different places in
space so once we Define the series of
simultaneity surfaces this foliation of
the causal graph those are our
space-like hypersurfaces those are our
all of space at a moment in time and
when we talk about Flux Of causal edges
was saying that there are causal edges
which go from one space like
hypersurface to the next there are other
causal edges that that that's we're
looking at sort of the projection of
these causal edges into the direction
that corresponds to the successive uh
space likee hypersurfaces and
essentially what that's doing is it's
giving us a more invariant more
mathematically defined way to basically
see how much activity there is in the
network and that activity in the network
we identify with energy I'm really
surprised that the identification is as
simple as that but it is and once we
have that we can start saying well how
does the presence of energy affect for
example geodesics shortest paths in this
network and we can discover that the
presence of energy deflects these
geodesics and that's exactly what the
Einstein equations say should happen
because they're relating the curvature
of space which is what determines the
curving of those shortest paths the
curvature of space is proportional to
essentially the energy density so that
that's kind of how that
works
um
gosh uh Rudy is asking on the topic of
conferences do you think technology will
change the format will panels and
standard talks remain constant will AIS
one day be participants well you know
even a combination of pandemic plus
technology changed conferences a lot
from uh and you know virtual I have been
doing kind of video conference
conferences
for let's
see 26 years at least uh well I had been
doing at the beginning of the pandemic
maybe 23 years or whatever um but uh uh
for a long time but um the sort of the
virtual became much more common and that
has advantages that there are lots of
conferences and get togethers where sort
of the the cost of doing it as a thing
where everybody flies into a place is
just way too high it will never happen
and it will never work with people's
schedules and things like that so things
can happen that couldn't have happened
get togethers can happen that couldn't
have happened before and just like you
know I'm I'm talking to you in this live
stream and that's a thing of this sort
of modern virtualized times um that uh
you know I've given lots of talks in
person but at a much lower density than
these live streams and this is a this is
a thing of modern times now you know to
what extent will AI be relevant to this
I don't know I think that um uh there
sort of very practical things like
summarizing uh things that are going on
like you can come in late to a talk you
can say give me the to the AI Give me a
summary of what's been said so far
that's a thing that sort of changes the
human Dynamic of that in terms of the
the sort of the value of sort of human
interaction I have to say I think that
what we've seen well for very
specialized conferences it's kind of
like people are just going to get sort
of fact fact fact maybe there's a click
of people who are little community of
people who like to hang out together
because they all study this particular
specific area but I think that the the
things that I often find the most
valuable are these kind of conferences
where there's all kinds of people meling
around and they all do different kinds
of things and you get to meet those
people and that becomes in a sense the
focus of the conference rather than oh
there's going to be a talk here a talk
there I think the other thing that maybe
is becoming more common is kind of
interview style presentations at
conferences so to speak
which are I think both but they're a lot
easier for the speaker and they're I
think they're often a lot more a lot
more gets communicated and a lot because
in a sense if you're if you're giving a
talk there's a whole Arc of that talk
and often you feel like you have to give
you you know you really do need to give
that full Arc but actually if it was
just like there's this question okay
given the answer you've given to that
question there's another question might
be in a different direction that can the
sort of total density of information
communicated is actually higher than in
that kind of whole Arc of the
talk now in terms of AIS doing
interviews that's an interesting
possibility I don't know I mean if if
really the point is just draw out the
speaker or for example organize
questions people are asking uh through
some AI that's an interesting thought
I've not really not really um uh
considered that um so uh
uh right I think that's um the my my
immediate thoughts on that subject
stepen is asking here what is it like to
actually run a task on a
supercomputer um most supercomputers are
are these days very parallel computers
they have you know tens of thousands of
CPUs and so on and uh uh you know
actually in wol language there's quite
simply function like parallel table make
a table of things where each element of
the table is being worked out on a
different computer um and you know I I
do this routinely my my personal mini
supercomputer is about
150 uh separate CPU cores on computers
that are dotted around actually not even
all of them but but the particular set
of computers kind of at at my house and
um I routinely set sort of parallelize
this computation across all these
computers I have to say it's often a
pain in the neck because these computers
by the time you're connecting to all
these computers and there's some one of
them is down and there's an issue and it
has to back up and it has to retry and
so on that can be kind of an annoying
piece of of usually largely automated
but sort of computer
wrangling but
then it's like um then it it's just you
know things are happening on these
different parallel pieces it's then
important to know sort of how is the how
is the distribution of the task working
because you know if the whole task
requires a thousand different pieces to
be completed and one of them is a
holdout and it takes you know a year of
CPU time to complete you're not going to
have a happy time because all your other
999 already finished but you're just
waiting for that one hold out so it's
it's sort of a complicated art to
distribute sort of the load as well as
possible possible I think um uh other
than that I mean I would say that that
most supercomputer systems have these
job submission systems um that uh well
doesn't isn't true for the ones that I
have personally because I'm I'm sort of
in a first approximation their only user
and so it's like well I have to just
remember am I already running something
all these things if I am if I try and
run a second thing it's not going to run
very fast um but uh so I'm I'm I'm a
very simple kind of job submission
program it's just me remembering oh I'm
I'm doing an overnight run on all these
computers I can't do a second one but in
the more sort of official case where
many people are trying to use a
supercomputer there tend to be these uh
job management job submission
systems uh that uh that handle that
actually in Moran language for example
there's a um uh function remote batch
submit which submits kind of just lumps
of Orphan language code to be run on
batch in a batch way on cloud services
or
supercomputers and um that's something
where the only difference from what I
was describing is the answer doesn't
come back to you immediately you're sort
of sending it you're submitting this
batch job and it goes off and you know
maybe a few hours later it sends you
mail and says it's finished now you can
click somewhere or you can go into a
wolf from language notebook and you can
start looking at the results that you
got but that's that's kind of the
experience
um let's
see
uh Rebel is asking don't you fear humans
will start to live mostly in digital
worlds and most of cognitive energy will
be spent on problems there and not in
Natural
Science well I mean welcome to the world
of video games you know I think it's an
interesting in question whether there is
and I'm not a video game player really
actually at all I'm hopeless and and not
adequately knowledgeable in that area
but it's like we can do an experiment in
natural science or we can go into
Minecraft and we can do an experiment
now turns out the physics there is is
kind of a simple imitation of the
physics that we see in real life we can
certainly imagine a game in which the
physics is utterly different from what
we see in real life and we could be
spending our sort of game time trying to
reverse engineer the physics that's been
put into the game just like we try to
quotes reverse engineer the laws of
nature to see how our physical universe
is put together or how we perceive it's
it's it's operating so this question of
well will we eventually get to a point
where most of our effort is spent kind
of exploring what we would today see as
video games yes I think that's a a
likely possibility and I think the thing
that to me right now as a non-v video
game player not well connected to that
kind of Paradigm that's like boy that's
a really bad outcome for Humanity but I
think one of the features of history is
that any given time people say I'm doing
this
because and the because changes and
sometimes in a different age that
because seems just bizarre I mean one
that's not terribly bizarre but you know
dominated uh a bunch of you know a
thousand years ago or something is like
I'm doing this for the greater glory of
God and you know what does that mean
well if you have certain religious
beliefs that has a definite meaning but
it also has it's also quite abstract at
some level it's at some level it might
be a statement you know it's or another
statement that's very common in the in
the uh I would say in in modern times in
the tech industry is we're doing this to
make the world a better place which I I
view as being kind of a modern version
of for the greater glory of God but um
you know in it's it's kind of a a um
these are all things that are sort of
explanations why are we doing this you
know at some other times in history it
might have been like what do you what do
you wish for people do you wish for
people to for example lead a fulfilled
life okay that might be a current desire
do you wish for them to lead uh at a
different time in history it might have
been to die well and uh you know for the
next life so to speak or or just as a
matter of Honor or do you want do you
know at different times in history
people have had very different sets of
goals which at another time in history
just look bizarre so for example in uh
you know the the the individualist kind
of self-help is kind of uh push started
I suppose 195 1960s where it's kind of
like you know do the best for yourself
so to speak whereas at other times in
history in other cultures perhaps it's
kind of do the best for the community
that's the important thing as opposed to
do the best for yourself and each of
these things has a that each have a
different kind of uh so that's what the
real point is do this you know make the
world a better place you know feel as
feel as as as as at peace with yourself
as you can whatever whatever the goal is
those goals have changed over time and
there is no absolute to what those goals
are those are just the goals that we
decide are the goals we should have and
so similarly if we imagine a future
world in which kind of it's it's all
sort of uploaded Souls playing video
games so to speak in that environment
there will surely also be objectives
just as there are today of people
wanting to you know maintain their
streak in some social media platform or
achieve things that I wouldn't
necessarily even know or understand to
my detriment in you know in video games
you know get to the next level in this
video game do you know achieve this this
objective in this video game I think the
only difference right now is that we
still feel like I think for the most
part games are kind of like there was a
puppet master who defined the game but I
think it is not a far reach and it's
already happened with lots of games that
like the story of computational
irreducibility the the original you
know
Puppeteer made the game made the rules
but the consequences of those rules they
could not foresee and in fact the only
way to get to the consequences is
essentially to play the game and see
what happens and so that then makes game
play much more like the sort of the the
process of living in the world and
experiencing nature and and so I think
and and in that situation many of the
things that we now say that's the point
that's what's uh you know that's the
objective that we're satisfying will
seem much more similar between the sort
of video game case and the and the case
in nature so this question of for
example you know given that there were
rules put into the game but then we had
to sort of just play the game to see
what happens well so it is with nature
there were rules put into nature we
don't necessarily know what they are we
have a much better idea now than we did
a few years ago but the consequen of
those rules what can happen in nature as
a result is it possible for us to go
faster than light is it possible for us
to do this or that these are things
which just from knowing the rules it's
extremely difficult usually impossible
to determine that for certain we really
have to just try out lots of experiments
invent lots of Technology those kinds of
things and I think so it will be in the
case of video games or you know what I'm
referring to as video games the
virtualized world that that it will
still be the case that it's like well
can we build this thing can we make this
you know what are they called um uh mods
no that's that's a little different but
can we make these these features in the
game that allow us to do this or that
thing and that will be kind of the
environment it won't be the true
environment of Nature and it'll be the
environment of our experienced nature
and by the way there is no true
environment of nature it's all what we
experience it's all kind of kind of
where we how we perceive the ruad I
don't think and and how we perceive it
with our current biological physical
instantiation versus how we will
perceive the ruad same ruad different
perception when we're hanging out in the
video game is is it's interesting and
and this my assumption is that there
needs to be a continuity between our
experience of the physical world in our
biological form and the experience of
the kind of virtual world in our
virtualized form or or we won't even
recognize it as being sort of the same
thing we won't recognize that that yes
we've successfully transplanted Our Kind
Of Consciousness from the biological
world to the purely virtual
computational world and and how that
will work I mean my guess is that to
make that work it will have to be a
gradual process that will gradually have
you know the neural connections and this
and that and the other and it'll
gradually be like what does it feel like
to have part of your brain be just sort
of executing digitally somewhere else
and then we kind of feel like this and
then we more of it is executing
digitally and eventually it's kind of we
made the transition so to speak my guess
is that's how it will work just as if
you take somebody from a thousand years
ago and you plunk them in in modern
society modern technology they will be
somewhat lost but if you you have to
give them a path actually it's sort of
an interesting case and point of this
and it makes me feel a little bit of
self-improvement for for myself is with
video games I if you plun me down in
front of a modern advanced video game I
would not have a clue what to do you
know it takes me it would take me sort
of there's a a learning path that I
would have to go through that goes which
I should do because it's kind of
embarrassing I don't know these things
um but uh I I I I have so many things I
want to do I don't feel like I should be
doing these things where I'm sort of uh
I like to play a game where I invent the
whole game so to speak rather than when
some part of it is invented for me but
in a sense you might say well why am I
interested in Natural Science because
that too is a game where part of it has
been invented for me and I mean I
suppose if I'm to really be
introspective I'm actually more
interested in cases where I get to
define the formal rules than I am in
sort of reverse engineering the
actualities of natural science so I
suppose it is a consistent uh you know
if if um if if sort of uh I don't know
what personality trait that it's kind of
like I'm uh the same thing that makes me
interested in and not so interested in
video games makes me sort of all the
more interested in rules that I Define
myself and what the consequences
are so
uh I
think you know a very an interesting
question would be if you are looking
from the outside at this box with a
trillion souls in it that are all kind
of interpreting the universe in certain
ways and you look at what is happening
in that box and you say do these Souls
have an inner experience you're looking
from the outside do these Souls have an
inner experience of understanding the
world in which they're living or not
same thing you can ask for a human does
that human whose brain we can probe only
in very coarse ways with kind of you
know brain recording of various kinds
does that human have an inner experience
of understanding what's going on in the
world hard to tell but it will be
interesting to know if there is sort of
a mechanism for if there's sort of a
test of you see these bits that are
representing the iners of the brain
whether they're a human brain with
biological one or whether they're a
virtualized brain um you know you see
the bits can you tell what the inner
experience what can you tell about the
inner experience of that brain
challenging but I suspect there are some
things one can say and and that would be
an interesting challenge in uh kind of
to what
extent well to what extent we can uh
attribute other mind Minds in other
things because it's kind of a um uh a
thing that um um has you know one of our
fundamental assumptions about the world
is we have an inner experience of what's
Happening inside our minds but we don't
know for sure that there even is an
inner experience in another mind we talk
to a person they seem to be doing mind
like things that remind us of the
sensations that we have ourselves we try
and talk to a cat does the cat have a
mind-like experience like ours probably
not so much so you know it's a question
of to what extent can we make this
Assumption of Mind likeness in another
thing and if we could see that in sort
of the bit patterns of the disembodied
soul in the in this kind of uh uh
virtualized sort of game like
environment that would be an interesting
thing to know whether there's a
signature of that kind of uh I am a a
mind with an internal view of
things let's
see Jamie is asking would it be possible
at some point to have both a digital and
a physical Consciousness simultaneously
and when you sleep they combine to sort
of absorb the knowledge of both
experiences it's kind of interesting
look I think that in some sense we are
Outsourcing all kinds of our
capabilities to computers whether it's a
remote webcam that's watching something
whether it's the memory of you know my
big archives of everything I've I've
done that are on my computer we're sort
of Outsourcing things that were just in
our brains and I think uh the the sort
of one of the features of Human
Experience is that we do feel like we
experience a single thread of time so
there is ultimately the attention system
of brains which says this is what I'm
experiencing this is what I'm paying
attention to and it's in one thread and
so when we see that remote webcam we're
still pulling that remote webcam into
that one thread of experience I think
it's an interesting question whether
what it would feel like to have more
than one thread of experience I think
there may be some things that we
consider to be sort of uh uh psychiatric
issues where people sort of dissociate
multiple threads of experience um and uh
uh for better or worse I fortunately
have don't have that personal experience
um so you know it's hard to know what
that really feels like from the inside
so it um I think you know that that's a
case where what would it be like to have
multiple threads of experience and
really have them sort of rattling around
in one's mind I don't know and you know
maybe some people do have that kind of
experience maybe it does not match well
with kind of operating in the world as
the world currently built I mean it's
kind of like people discuss you know the
world is built in a certain way we have
uh and Society is built in a certain way
and Society is built in a way that's
good for hopefully many of the people in
the society it may not be good for the
not so you know what people you know
whatever it is the non- neurotypical
whatever that might mean you know the
the uh one can imagine there are other
parts of of society maybe which are well
built for that and it's a different part
from the part that's wellb built for the
usual experience and so most of our
Human Experience is this kind of
single-threaded human experience and
that's kind of the thing that seems to
work well in the world uh for for how
things how things operate and I don't
know what it would be like uh when we're
my my guess is it's going to be single
thread of experiences in charge now when
that single thread of experience is
digital and when it's just probing for
example let's say we replace biological
brains with digital brains but we still
have bodies with with the you know with
biological things and we've got nerve
fibers going out from the brain to
wiggle our fingers and things like this
what will that be like and then
occasionally there will be signals
coming back from the biological us to
the digital us saying by the way you
just stubbed your toe or something or by
the way uh this um you know your hunger
sensor which wasn't part of your digital
brain is now firing so to speak so I
it'll be an interesting thing what what
that um uh you know what that feels like
and uh uh you know so many things about
The Human Condition will change when we
have sort of a a major Digital Way of
existing um and I'm I'm not sure that
that Civilization as it currently exists
you know whether it will survive that
transision in a form that will be
recognizable to us today is quite
unclear to me now whether to the
entities of the time they'll say oh my
gosh the roof is caving in you know the
sky is falling it's it's all disastrous
or whether they'll say hey we're having
a great time here you know we're doing
all kinds of cool things we're we're um
uh even though there's a lot of the
value system that we had from our
biological experience is no longer
relevant we're having a great time over
here um I think that but yet to us today
it's like my gosh what a what a disaster
there there there are you know all these
um you know these trillion souls in a
box playing video games you know that
looks really bad it looks like something
you know it looks like the end of
history and it's all it's all sort of
it's all gone to hell so to speak but
you know it's worth remembering that if
you were to look at sort of today
Society from the point of view of
society a thousand years ago you would
oh I don't know to pick on religion
again for example you would oh my gosh
people are not praying for some fraction
of the time or most are not of the day
that's a shocker you know that's what we
would have expected that's part of
humanity as of you know a thousand years
ago or something it doesn't happen to be
in much of the world today but similarly
people saying oh you know I'm
uh well even even from longer ago you
know I'm trying to accumulate more stuff
as I go through life to other people of
of of long ago or different cultures and
so on it's like private property
property what what is that what what's
that doesn't make any sense they might
say you know it's all about kind of the
community or something um and and then
to you know at different times one has
different there's different principles
about how what seems to be the
worthwhile thing to do and I think it's
it's it's hard to
project to say you know this is this is
an issue always with judging history and
judging the future and so on it's like
at the time when people did X you might
say today that was a shocking thing to
have done but the time it was done that
was just part of the culture of what was
going on and so similarly there are
things that we might imagine about the
future where we say that would be a
shocking outcome but yet to the Future
to the entities of the future so to
speak it will seem like a fine outcome
it will seem to make kind of cultural
sense in that moment of of of time and I
think that so you know I think the um
it's it's very hard to judge the future
from the present to judge the past from
the present it's I think uh it's worth
just remembering that you know to to the
entity in the moment there is a certain
per C there's a certain feeling and you
can even you can sort of recurse on this
question is what they're feeling at that
time something good to feel and that's
you know even the feeling that oh I
don't know you um
uh the feeling some some feeling that
you might have at a certain moment you
might at another time in history that
feeling might might have been a shocking
feeling I mean for instance I don't know
I won that
battle I killed my
opponent okay at times in history that's
like you feel good about that at other
times in history that's like no that's
not how things you know that that's
that's terrible that would be you know
that would be incredibly traumatic to be
in that you know in with that feeling of
that of that having happened at a
different time like now in in history so
to speak
and much of of what happens now so
anyway a few thoughts on
that um let's see Pro is asking what if
you take someone's videos articles Life
notes lots of things feed them into a
specialized AI make it answer the
questions behave almost like that person
uh that technology is not so far away
feels like sort of a a Consciousness
transfer do you think it can be trans
classified as that yes I mean I've
certainly thought about that even for
myself but it's kind of like I've put
like 5050 million words of stuff out
there and that's probably enough to
reconstruct a pretty good approximation
to me actually somebody just sent me
some once one thing that was produced by
NM That was supposed to be sounding like
me they just sent it to me this morning
it was terrible awful it didn't sound
like me to Me Maybe other people it does
sound like me I have noticed before that
things that to other people when I see
what an llm produc say That's supposed
to sound like somebody else I often say
that's pretty good but when it's for me
I kind of know that's not how I talk
that's not what I say that's not what I
would say in that case so I don't know
what it takes to get above that bar but
my guess is it's going to be possible to
get above that bar and and then there
are many interesting ethical questions I
mean there's there's all sorts of
questions I was just uh exposed to one
of these uh in a discussion recently the
um about
uh what is the term now being used grief
Bots I think um that is a an avatar of a
person who's died and under what
circumstances who gets to determine that
that thing exists what do you get to do
with it how does it uh uh you know is it
is it good for people to have that under
what circumstan is it good for people to
have that how does that all work that's
something that I think is a is an
increasingly relevant question I mean
for somebody like me for example because
I do have an awful lot of stuff that is
raw material from which such a thing
could be made that certainly is is an
interesting question and uh I suppose
it's it's kind of like in in the time of
ancient Egypt it's kind of like unless
it was written down uh kind of it
doesn't have a it doesn't have a
longtime life so to speak um but uh and
and that worked out really well for the
Egyptians as in we can now read their
you know in their we can read their
inscriptions and we can know things
about their lives 4,000 years later and
so maybe the answer is well you know in
so far as one seeking the eternal life
which has been something that us humans
have been often interested in uh it's
kind of like well put up that you know
let that Avatar of yourself be be exist
as well as possible as far into the
future as possible you know perhaps
that's a that's the that's the analog of
put away those those uh um those things
in the you know uh uh put all those
extra bits around the mummy or inside
the mummy or whatever for the Egyptians
so to speak um and uh uh maybe that's
the maybe that's the analog of
that um LC is commenting imagine those
entities perfectly conscious and
everything but only digital come to
vastly outnumber us biological ones
yeah I mean that will surely happen
because it is much easier to clone a
digital thing than to clone a biological
thing at least for now um I mean it's
always amazing to me you know we have an
awful lot of cells in our bodies 100
trillion that's that's a lot and it's
awfully you know the the number when
things are molecular scale even cells
are much bigger than molecular scale
there's a big variation of the sizes of
cells but um you know
when there's awful lot of stuff awful
lot of distinct things that fit in
things that are kind of human scaled and
so I think it's it's not
clear yeah I mean I also what it what
counts as biological is going to get
complicated I mean we're going to have
more and more kind of um uh um more and
more of these um uh um
uh more and more sort of things like
artificial tissues and so on we'll have
more and more sort of interaction
between nanotechnology and biology more
and more things where we can kind of
replace that blood cell by some kind of
manufactured engineered thing it's not
completely clear what the difference is
because it's kind of like well that
blood cell was made by some molecular
processes and out of the end of that PL
a blood cell and then we have this kind
of set of molecular manufacturing and
out of the end of the molecular Factory
so to speak plops an artificial red
blood cell it's not clear how different
those kinds of things are so uh in any
case I I'm I'm um yes this question
about sort
of well there all kinds of questions
about in so far as collective decisions
have to be made about the world and in
so far as there is sort of there are all
sorts of digital entities that are
starting to populate the world um you
know how does that all work and um how
does one and and you
know at what point does one decide
that the happiness of digital entities
is important well certainly by the time
it is reasonable to think that by the
time the future of some human thread of
experience for a human is in that
digital form that its happiness is
relevant but now imagine that you've
converted your sort of Consciousness
somehow to this digital form you're
disconnected from the biological one you
got this digital one it's it's your
future so to speak and it's you at some
level and then you copied a million
times well does each of those million
copies have the same right to uh life
liberty in the pursuit of happiness so
to speak as the one original one or does
it get diluted by a factor of a million
or what happens you know these are these
are complicated issues you know we've
had the idea for our species that seems
like the obvious idea that for every
human every individual human it's kind
of like there's a certain bundle of
Rights and and uh a certain bundle of
things that it's like human by human but
when you take that one human and you
clone it effectively you digitally clone
it a million times what happens to that
and how does that compare and let's say
you've got if you decided that uh for
every one of those digital clones it's
got as much right to decide what's
happening as as as any other one then
you say Well it becomes a clone war so
to speak not to sound too Star Trek Star
Wars like but a digital Clone War as in
I've got a quadrillion clones therefore
my views are more important than you
who's only got a trillion clones and
actually it's kind of interesting as I
as I'm talking this through that that is
so bizarrely similar to the struggle for
life in biological evolution that is the
winner is the one who has the most
progeny um it's it's kind of like the
traits you have are going to be the
winning traits if you are have the most
children so to speak over at least over
the course of generations you know the
butterfly that has the purple wing
that does better than the butterfly that
has the green wings um and you know the
purple wing butterfly tends to have
purple wing butterfly kids then that's
going to win out and that's the story of
biological evolution but if if what you
say is in the in the kind of struggle
for Digital Life in the case of of of AI
it's like you've got you've got the one
that's cloned a million times the one
that's cloned a billion times if the one
that's cloned a billion times it feels
like you can can clone as much as you
want now now that's sort of interesting
because in the end you hit resource
boundaries in the end you're cloning you
know you have clones of you expanding at
the speed of light and then you're
hitting kind of the Roar edges of what
is kind of physically possible I suppose
it's an interesting thing to Think
Through imagine a kind of I haven't
thought about this before but imagine
kind of a digital ex existence that is
kind of in the ruad there's only one
ruad you don't get to escape the ruad
you're you're always existing there
you're always computations taking place
in the ruad and but you say I'm going to
you know my thread of experience my
thread of meanness is going to somehow
be spread through all these different uh
kind of pieces of the ruad and and
somebody else's thread of meanness is
spread through some other pieces of the
ruad and in a sense it's kind of like
how does the ruad become more about me
me me so to speak rather than about some
other entity and uh sort of how does
that work and there are clearly
constraints like the meanus can only
spread at the speed of light in physical
space it can only spread at the maximum
entanglement speed in branchial space it
can only spread at the maximum Ral speed
in Ral space those speeds are very high
but there is a limit and there are in a
sense the um uh it's telling you that
there's a uh that sort of those are
those are some constraints now what
happens when there's sort of competition
between the me and the you I'm not sure
how to think about that and maybe the
way to think about it is incredibly
similar to the way that we actually
think about biological evolution maybe
it turns out natural selection is
actually something that is sort of will
be played out at that level as well I
mean I I've sort of thought a little bit
about the kind of the society the AIS
but you know this is one of the things
that one kind of learns from doing
computational stuff is or learns from
actually from physics as well it's like
there can be an awful lot of things that
is you know you have to once you've got
to example one of the things that held
me back in our physics project was that
I had this view of of physics as being
somehow computational but I could not
imagine that physics was the
unbelievably propagate waster of
computational resources that it is that
there are all these branches of history
and they all you know branching out and
branching out and at every moment
there's many many more branches being
made and it's just unbelievable amounts
of computation happening and and for me
I still had this kind of was holding on
to this idea computation is kind of a a
a valuable and kind of thing your
Universe can't just waste it in that
completely crazy way but actually it
does and I think this kind of this is
part of sort of overcoming one's one's
sort of existing paradigms and realizing
that yes sort of things like when when
we thought about okay we've got an AI we
got one AI it's really cool but what
about if we had a million AIS or a
billion AIS or we filled every fragment
of the universe with what we can think
of as an AI That's sort of an
interesting kind of end point that um I
I guess you know we're still a little
bit stuck in we've got one Ai and we're
very proud of it rather than the what
happens when there's a whole society of
AIS or kind of a whole RADS worth of
AIS so anyway that that's um a few
thoughts actually I have not so thank
you guys for leading me in this
particular uh uh Direction in the ruad
of um uh of understanding these kinds of
things it's an interesting thing to to
think through and uh by the way I see
somebody commenting that um uh this is
like many science fiction Adventures um
yeah and I I I must say that I think
some of these things about thinking
through alien minds I think that is a
very important thing for us particularly
right now as AI come more on the scene
understanding what alien minds are like
it's sort of in some sense it's a little
bit like the I I I mean I suppose it's
the ultimate multiculturalism so to
speak understand the alien minds and
it's something which even within sort of
the cultures of of the world it's
something that sort of getting inside
that way of thinking is is always
challenging may very difficult in many
cases but to kind of imagine what it's
like to be in an alien mind is is yet
more but somehow revealing I think of
both what one can know and what one
cannot know even within sort of human
minds and different human cultures so I
think it's a it's a really interesting
exercise and and one that is
particularly pertinent right now with
the kind of arrival of the AIS to to
think that through and I can imagine
being able to EXP Express those ideas as
much in science fiction as one can in
kind of the the sort of cold facts of
what will go on I mean imagine what it's
like to be a uh some sort of this in the
struggle for life with um or struggle
for I don't we don't call it life I
don't know what you should call it the
struggle for existence with um uh all of
these other competing sort of digital
cloned Minds you know what's what does
that feel like what can we describe that
can we humanize that experience is it
you know what's it like I mean I could
even imagine I don't think one one
hasn't seen this really too much is kind
of what's what does it really feel like
to be an ant or something I know there's
uh the bugs life movie which I haven't
seen in a very long time which has some
some versions of that about particularly
about scale and so on but what does it
really feel like to be some sort of in
in part of some collective species like
that I'm not sure you know I don't know
how to think about that and perhaps sort
of the fictionalized account helps one
potentially to sort of uh be able to get
a better internal feeling for what that
would be like but it's something I think
is you know it's a it's a challenging
thing to do all right I should wrap up
there and and go back to some much more
prosaic uh things in my in my day job
here but um
uh thanks um
thanks for prompting um all kinds of
interesting thoughts here and uh I look
forward to seeing you guys some uh
another live stream or at least um
imagining and this is again a very
digitalized virtualized experience for
me um and
interestingly I don't know maybe I
should will you know for some reason it
is still a a a human experience of some
kind even though this is sort of a
deeply virtualized situation um by the
way I might say for next week um it is
the time of our annual W from technology
conference which is online this year and
so accessible to people more easily
somebody was asking about the evolution
of conferences and um we have one coming
up uh just next week where um
uh uh where there it's it's all virtual
so it's it's quite accessible you know I
have to say things we've experimented
with for example having people in sort
of a physical space and moving around a
virtualized physical
space I really thought that was going to
be very compelling and I pushed very
hard for a company I've been an advisor
to to to uh to deploy at the beginning
of the pandemic uh such a thing I I
think it could have been slightly better
deployed but they did not terrible job
but it's sort of interesting the extent
to which
people can or cannot interact well in
that kind of virtualized
virtualized similar of of physical space
so to speak I'm not sure if we're doing
an experiment like that at our upcoming
conference but in any case there will be
certainly um uh a um uh various
opportunities to interact virtually uh
at our conference next week all right
well thanks very much and uh bye for
now